[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israel ich bin gerade auf der macworld
messe in hannover und die tech world
findet auf der infa messestadt eine
richtig große kreativ messe und wir sind
jetzt schon beim dritten tag heute ist
montag und wir bauen jetzt hier gerade
nur ein bisschen was auf und bereiten
uns auf die zuschauer später vor gerade
halb neun ich habe jetzt noch eineinhalb
stunden zeit hier ein bisschen was
vorzubereiten
und während ich jetzt den teig noch
vorbereiter und den kuchen schon mal vor
backe könnt ihr euch schon mal die
ersten zwei tage anschauen
[Musik]
los ging es dieses mal an einem
donnerstagnachmittag
hier haben wir uns einen bus gemietet
weil wir einfach so viele personen sind
und auch ganz viel equipment haben was
wir mitnehmen müssen und die fahrt nach
hannover sind ungefähr sechs bis acht
stunden je nach verkehr und so kann man
sich beim autofahren dann immer
abwechseln und während der fahrt schon
einiges besprechen und auch planen und
wir sind dieses mal mittags dann
losgefahren damit wir freitagmorgens
eben gleich mit dem aufbau beginnen
können
[Musik]
unterwegs habe ich dann mit andrea meine
rezepte geplant und werden dann den
einkaufszettel geschrieben
für so eine messe kommt dann wirklich
ganz viel zusammen und wir müssen dann
kiloweise lebensmittel einkaufen damit
meine zuschauer und besucher dann
einfach auch ganz viel probieren können
[Musik]
die kate messe war dieses jahr teil der
infa messe in hannover und es ist
wirklich ein riesen messegelände und
dort hatten wir einen ganz ganz großen
stand mit ungefähr 600 quadratmeter und
so hatten wir einfach genug platz für
alle unsere zuschauer
[Musik]
und parallel zu uns ist ein moratorium
scharf an und mit batik gefahren mit
insgesamt drei lkws und die waren
wirklich voll beladen mit unserem online
shop mit dem messestand mit dem ganzen
sonstigem equipment und wir müssen halt
immer so früh anreisen und auch mit ganz
vielen personen weil wir den stand
wirklich von a bis z komplett selbst
aufbauen
und da hatte noch wirklich jeder was zu
tun
zuerst wird immer der pinkfarbene
teppich verlegt und dann werden auch die
wasseranschlüsse für spülmaschine und
fürs waschbecken gelegt und dann bauen
die männer hat die traversen auf das ist
ziemlich schwer deswegen machen wir
frauen damit mit und in dieser zeit gehe
ich dann mit andrea meist einkaufen und
wir besorgen dann eben schon die
lebensmittel und die getränke
[Musik]
und sobald die traversen dann stehen
wird dann eingerichtet und dekoriert
damit einfach am ende alles stimmig
aussieht und meistens sind wir dann
wirklich von morgens acht bis abends 22
uhr mit dem aufbau beschäftigt
und sobald ich ein paar freie minuten
habt schreibe ich dann immer ein paar
autogramme vor die wir dann einfach am
nächsten tag verteilen können damit man
da nicht so lange anstehen muss und hier
seht ihr jetzt den kompletten aufbau
einfach nochmal im zeitraffer
[Musik]
und während sich fordert dann die messe
halle füllt und die zuschauer so langsam
an unseren stand kommen bereite ich
hinten in der küche immer meist noch
maßvoll und dann kündigt mich der murat
an der begrüßt an unsere zuschauer und
dann starten wir beide in der küche
[Musik]
also auf den messen ist es grundsätzlich
so dass ich morgens in der küche anfange
und koch und back dann dort etwas und in
der zeit können meine besucher fragen
stellen und das ist da noch immer ganz
schön denn oft erkenne ich viel
zuschauer auch die kenne ich schon
einfach über die youtube facebook oder
über die instagram profile und dann ist
noch immer ganz schön die gesichter zu
den vielen namen zu sehen
und vor allem ist dann halt immer eine
schöne gelegenheit für meine besucher
einfach auch mal was aus meiner küche zu
probieren
[Musik]
und nach dem ersten block in der küche
bin ich dann draußen bei den zuschauern
da machen wir dann gemeinsam fotos und
ich gebe autogramme und danach geht es
dann für mich eben wieder in der küche
weiter
[Musik]
da seid ihr ja wieder ich spaziere
gerade hinten in meinem rückzugsort ja
das ist hier
hier kann ich ein bisschen sitzen und
ich schreiben in der zeit schon ein paar
autogramme vor nämlich aus dem grund
damit später draußen einfach nicht so
lange dauert und damit ich so viele
menschen wie möglich in der
autogrammstunde sehen kann und auch
fotos machen kann singen sitze ich hier
in der kleinen pause und schreibt die
eben vor und habe ich mir auch so einen
kleinen zelle ort gemacht und zwar mit
all den schönen sachen die ich von
meinem zuschauer mitbekommen habe ganz
viele tolle mädchen und jungs und frauen
und männer die mir hier plakate zaubern
im hintergrund zum beispiel schaut euch
das bild mal an hat die liebe paula
gemacht gezeichnet und gemalt heißt auch
instagram des team mehr und sie
besuchten die eigentlich schon fast seit
der ersten messe also echte mich
wahnsinnig talentiert liebe paula
richtig schön dieses bild und ob es
andere noch die ganzen anderen tollen
plakate sind wunderschön und peter
schenk mir trotzdem nicht aber über
selbstgemachte freue ich mich natürlich
immer sehr
jetzt geht es gleich los wenn wir noch
zwei bis drei minuten bis 10 uhr und
dann werde ich nach vorne gehen und
gleich kochen und backen und mich und
meine zuschauer unterhalten
bis gleich
[Musik]
und natürlich muss jeden tag vor und
nach der messe noch einmal aufgeräumt
werden geputzt und eingeräumt werden
damit einfach alles wieder schön
ordentlich aussieht
[Musik]
und hier seht ihr jetzt ein paar
einblicke wie ich auf der messe in der
küche stehe und koche und backe und ein
paar fragen meiner zuschauer beantworten
den hefeteig und davor mich jetzt so
kleine etwa gold verstärken golfbahn so
groß golfballgroße welt hin so ihr könnt
mir gerne jederzeit noch fragen stellen
hier sich demokraten
[Musik]
so ich sage was ich hier mache und zwar
nehme ich jetzt einen weichkäse und zwar
ist das eine kuh milch käse von ghazi
und das ist so ein käse ich weiß ich
viele kennen denn wahrscheinlich nicht
auf typischen der bears gene und der
schmeckt sehr würzig und immer ganz
gerne eben gerade wenn ich irgendwas
füllen möchte oder zum überbacken auf
oder morgens mal einen toast rhein mit
dieser fusion track days ago
jetzt fühle ich dass hier einfach so ein
bisschen klaps zu und später bestreitet
[Musik]
und jetzt bestreite ich sie mit einer
mischung aus und aus joghurt unserer
joghurt des wegs hat meine mama nämlich
beigebracht dadurch werden sie eben auch
schon weit gekommen eine ganz tolle
fahre und es sich nicht ganz so hart wie
nur mit einem deswegen immer mit joghurt
dann nehme ich auf den zehn prozent
joghurt klar da schon ein bisschen
klettern aber es schmeckt auch viel
predator
[Musik]
so steht er in der küche dann auch neben
mir und dann sonst mehr in ruhe kochen
und backen oder
an
ein bisschen bestreichen
und dann bestreuen wir die noch mit
etwas schwarz kümmern
[Musik]
fix und fertig die messe ist frei
nach der messe in hannover sind wir dann
abends nach dem abbau noch afghanisch
essen gegangen und haben uns zuschauer
nämlich auf der messe besucht und von
dem restaurant berichtet und erzählt
und da sind wir dann hingegangen und
essen war wirklich super lecker und sehr
außergewöhnlich mit ganz verschiedenen
zutaten und gewürzen also dass
afghanische essen kann man wirklich
jedem empfehlen und gegessen haben
wieder lahm verschiedene reissorten viel
gemüse passten
es gab schon auch ein super leckeres
dessert aber ich finde im video sieht
man natürlich auch dass wir alle
ziemlich kaputt und müde waren und
deswegen konnten wir auch gar nicht so
lange bleiben und sind dann eben wieder
zurück ins hotel gefahren um im nächsten
tag heimzufahren
[Musik]
ja und so schnell weil es ein messer
jahr schon vorbei also ich muss sagen
ich bin eigentlich schon sehr traurig
dass es ja so schnell vorüber war
aber die ganzen messen waren wirklich
wunderschön angefangen hat sie im
februar in hamburg auf der macworld und
dann machen wir in dortmund in
friedrichshafen in berlin auf der ifa in
hannover auf der infa also wirklich ein
super schönes messer ja im globus bei
uns hier heimspiel war wirklich ganz
toll vielen dank noch mal an alle die
gekommen sind und die auch wirklich
lange weg auf sich genommen haben
obwohl wir das ja immer gar nicht wollen
also mich immer sehr unangenehm wenn ihr
ganz lange wege extra nur für uns
anreist aber es war wirklich wunderschön
danke an jeden einzelnen der da war ich
hoffe euch hat alles geschmückt und auch
gefallen und ich denke das ist immer
ganz schön einfach mal so ein bisschen
hinter die kulissen zu schauen von von
salis welt von meiner welt und für uns
ist es immer sehr schön euch dann
natürlich auch kennen zu lernen und die
nächsten messen für nächstes jahr die
geben wir euch natürlich noch
rechtzeitig bekannt
und da wollte ich noch sagen es sind
natürlich immer so dass wenn wir jetzt
kurzfristige sachen haben termine oder
einfach events die anstehen dann
verkünden wird er immer ganz gerne auf
facebook meistern einfach schneller geht
ich kann dann einfach mal ein posting
schreiben und online stellen und ich
kann nicht immer gleich sofort ein video
für youtube machen und deswegen wäre es
ganz gut falls sie uns da noch nicht
voll könnt ihr uns da gerne folgen also
mir aufs feld und da bekommt immer alle
infos und events rechtzeitig mitgeteilt
auch auf instagram und ich dachte auch
noch viele sachen schreiben und der
murat darf da auch immer ganz viel
schreiben da dort hoch dass ich auf
facebook postings sind legendär
also wenn du noch kein facebook hab ja
dann aber uns trotzdem folgen übrig sagt
mel durch an und folgen aber ihr könnt
auch falls jemand gar kein facebook hat
könnt ihr auch trotzdem immer meine
beiträge sehen also da muss man nicht
angemeldet sein
auch so verpasst da eben nichts ja das
nur nebenbei messejahr war toll und
januar betreiber im januar geht es schon
wieder weiter und die messetermine wie
gesagt geben wir euch bekannt
auch wann und wo und nächste woche das
ist es auch was sehr kurzfristiges das
heißt kurz rasiert für euch für mich
nicht jetzt schon länger nächste woche
am freitag bin ich in der landesschau im
es war zu sehen um 16 45 98
entschuldigung 845 und am sonntag bin
ich auf dem ulmer weihnachtsmarkt und
das ist dann von 16 bis 18 uhr eine live
sendung und damit viele zuschauer schon
geschrieben dass er mich da gerne
besuchen kommen möchten
aber ich rate euch eher davon ab denn
der ulmer weihnachtsmarkt ist
wunderschön aber der ist schon so recht
voll und wir mit da jetzt noch filmen
und bei der live wachsen und dabei sind
jetzt natürlich noch voller
das heißt ich hab da natürlich auch gar
keine gelegenheit irgendwie fotos mit
euch zu machen oder autogramme oder mich
mit euch überhaupt zu unterhalten
denn ich bin da wirklich sehr
eingespannt bei der vox sendung wir
haben vor eine generalprobe am sonntag
und acht um 16 uhr auch gerne
weihnachtsmarkt genau wirklich leid das
leiden live im fernsehen oder auch im
livestream anschauen genau das problem
ist einfach dass es nicht über den
messen das nutzlose zuschauer kümmern
können
auf jedes kind das können sie ruhig
bestehen auf jeder messe und
autogrammstunde wo ihr wart haben wir
zuschauer nur getränke geben ihr hass
extremisten und zu essen und beim
dienstantritt wartezeit genauso lange
ist genau damit mir da das nicht unsere
veranstaltung müssten ja nur fürs
fernsehen backt oder spinnen eigentlich
noch ganz genau
also spart euch will ich den weg und vor
allem es ist wahrscheinlich kalt und
wenn jetzt neue kinder so lange stehen
müsse egal ob die männer mit ihren
frauen das lange stehen müssen die armen
wenn ja also falls sie jetzt nicht
sowieso auf den ulmer weihnachtsmarkt
gehen wollte dann bleibt lieber daheim
und macht euch gemütlich vor dem
fernseher vor dem fernseher und dann
könnt ihr euch eben im fernsehen an
genau und wissen solche dinge die mir
auf facebook ich sofort noch schneller
hand geben können aber vor dem video
geht es halt eben nicht so schnell das
geht dann eben unter genau sie haben
ansonsten
es war einfach echt ein tolles jahr also
wenn ich so überlegt wie wir angefangen
haben letztes jahr mit den messen und
mit den kleinen tischen die wir am
anfang hatten wir sind papieren stecken
und jetzt haben wir einen wunderschönen
stand der natürlich noch größer werden
muss weil einfach immer mehr zuschauer
kommen immer mehr besucher und wir
müssen platz machen für alle dann wohl
inzwischen auf den messen eigene
messehalle genau und da wir versuchen
auch die über das west zu geben also
gehen immerhin versuchen irgendwie
sponsoren gut ist zu bekommen für die
zuschauer dass sie den trend geht zu
verteilen
aber das wissen sie wo dann wissen das
und wir gehen uns wirklich immer richtig
müde da richtig gerecht zu sein sind
aber nach dem messen auch immer für die
woche mindestens geplättet also seht ihr
in diesem video habt ihr ja das erste
mal so richtig mal den ablauf gesehen
von der anfahrt vom aufbau bis hin zum
ein bisschen über die messe dann der
abbau
das ist schon ziemlich anstrengend aber
am meisten wird am zu hause und haben
dann ein zwei tage und dann geht es
wieder los
wie auch immer ganz schön aber wir
freuen uns schon auf die messetermine
nächstes jahr freuen uns auf die
besucher aber wie gesagt nimmt keine zu
langen wege auf euch denn so besonders
ist ja so dass muss ehrlich sein biete
kanäle und geht euren eltern nicht auf
den keks geht man hat nicht auf den keks
ist es ohne gonzalez raum oder ehefrauen
ja ja es kam auch viel ja ich habe viele
schreiende männer gesehen genau diese
norwegen macht mit versüßen
dank ihren fans an gleich mit mid köln
richtig genau alles andere gehen wenn er
nicht genannt aber wie gesagt gut bei
facebook hat er minimal sofort kein
instagram auch dann freuen wir uns schon
aufs nächste jahr und wünschen euch
allen jetzt schon mal also ihr seht mich
dann auch ihre weiteren videos dieses
jahr aber ich wünsche euch trotzdem
jetzt schon mal eine schöne
vorweihnachtszeit eine schöne
weihnachtszeit video
morgen um 11 genau gibt ein plätzchen
video genau und ich freitag nicht
vergessen es wäre swr und am sonntag ist
er auch noch mal alles noch viel spaß
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal bis
dann macht's gut